chin talked me into Korean Barbie for
the Korean barbeque for the first time
how was it will give me just okay that's
right I was telling not because I'm a
huge fan of Korean barbecue it's amazing
but we don't know you're not supposed to
go to Seattle in that place I've never
heard of but but also I'm not racist
like that yeah I know but also let me
ask you about cream let's say you
represent all Korean barbecue you're the
President of the Federation for Korean
barbecue yeah so you either straight so
I got to go to dinner and then I have to
cook my own food well yeah okay listen
no no no before I just answer I got to
cook my own me hold on you see the meat
and then we'll have a grill for you and
you're gonna go to your specification
all because I can't order from a
steakhouse medium-rare and it comes
medium-rare but you might want to add a
little touch of medium-rare lose a
little more than a rare but I have to do
it all myself and monitor the goddamn
grill I'm trying to entertain my friend
I will admit that was clam BBQ there a
couple yeah a certain guys get left
behind they get they get forgotten
Buster got forgotten it starts to smoke
and you're like oh that poor guy that
guy's charcoal now and then me within I
don't know I'm tossing all the meats on
and then Jays like will flip down like
hey man I want to do this I'm gonna
chill yeah have that guy the waitress
[ __ ] do it I don't wanna do this it's
true there are two things that happen
one is don't take your ice off the meat
and that's hard to have a conversation
and two it gets a little hot on your
face if you're not careful yeah it does
and here's the other thing old racist
chin over here racist chin well it's
just a rich sexist why should call gay
he goes I know dude we just have to
monitor the meat this whole goddamn time
this is exhausting I want to do this he
goes dude usually I come with chicks and
in the old tradition of Korea the women
has to deal with them well well well
that's music you always invite
traditional Korean women or white girls
and like those are the rules [ __ ] sir
in light of the current situation that
dumb BMW MB am I expecting dudes to play
go to Korean barbeque or expectant women
to be flippin the meat cheese a corner
chin though oh me oh no
your progress while I was flipping it
myself
we're all equal and it's cash in that oh
yeah well Korean bastard it's [ __ ] up
he has gotten in he looked around us
wish our [ __ ] was around here no way
yeah like you're making that because I
wish I cut with poet chin we're in
Seattle dude humps relax that's what he
said yeah he goes I wish I'd get it cut
flip my chin when you don't tea like
this I know dude that and you kept your
mouth oh hey no dude I think I felt
think how I felt
he's like yo we need some more pork and
concert to flip the food
don't push it out of your the back ear
throat I'm just gonna say is a little
overrated dzasta long times this really
hot girl my acting class back in the day
and I said something like I was trying
to I liked her and I go I said I would
have sex with you I would have sex with
you I would just have sympathy for three
hours
they all do Brian
dudes yeah it's like there's nothing
you're gonna do that I haven't been
through I was with now like yo I've got
some power I was with a buddy and uh we
were getting coffee and a hot girl walk
by us we're in the middle of
conversation goes
he has sunglass and goes does this we're
outside a hog pretty hot like an eight
in LA walks by and wearing a little
millet conversations you like oh yes
whoa whoa and I go well I'm literally in
the middle of a discussion I go what
what what Manny is just like just take
it in I go you're construction worker
I've never seen a girl before but they
[ __ ] you do don't say that so what are
you here huling right you what the [ __ ]
you too old for this yeah like I don't I
don't have friends who don't whoa whoa
whoa whoa look at the like what yeah and
for like a scene at Chipotle after I did
Rogen shows Graham Chipotle before I
came here and there's this girl came in
ridiculous body like I almost felt bad
for it
it's you so
and she's in these jeans and her after
sight
titties just like pretty face decent
face but her body's like predict you
can't hide a she she wear a plastic bag
and be like dude your tits disaster so
she walks and you can tell right oh it's
just like yeah there's like all these
like they work for some like you know
just guys in their [ __ ] work outfit
and they're they're like they work for
the city that the yellow aprons on and I
hear Gus go mmhmm yeah guys I'd love a
bite of that and then they go around I
literally I die turnaround scheme the
worst looking like [ __ ] man what is
wrong with you get any what you'd like
about would you like goodbye to that
yeah what are you gonna do yeah what do
you do you know what the kind of guy she
looks like what she wants to [ __ ] not
you [ __ ] saps yeah like what's wrong
with you man I think it's a my felt bad
for though I felt bad for her I was like
God I'm us just a blessing a curse she
was shaped like a goddamn Bugatti ha it
would have read a mercy show these big
old pouty lips that we're all natural
she had no makeup it was a girl it's
what the French called on disaster film
disaster I mean I don't know you built
for one thing yeah that's right and
those gentlemen won't do it yeah they
want you all to know that they're not
gay taps into there that's the other
thing they bond they want to make sure
so you guys know so you know that I
would [ __ ] yeah
very cool man I think every man on the
planet feels that way but you don't need
to be super lame about yeah speaking of
dicks so Batman's penis made it into a
comic book and now it's a collector's
item no and a lot of people are
underwhelmed on TMZ yes let me see
they're starting a new comic book line
within DC that's separate from their
other storylines and where it's a darker
comic so they'll have much more things
like nudity sex violence and stuff like
that you see x-rays yeah yeah and so
their first comment book coming out is
gonna be a Batman series and it's gonna
be Nightwing as before you became
Nightwing
he took a minute and became Batman so it
was Robin he's good Robin took over
Batman's post after Bruce Wayne died and
so this is where the comic starts and
they have like an outline of his penis
so terrible people are mad that's the
area I grew up watching the animated
series and there was a scene where
Nightwing which is the same character
playing Batman in this series [ __ ]
Harlequin and I just expected more in my
head yes that that's hard to know let's
go soft he's just walking now I mean
it's the scene I would like to see more
girth and I would like to see a lower
hang and and I have to say this as well
does look like there I'd like to see
some heavy heavy impossible balls
because if you look how vascular he is
the Dark Knight is a very strong macho
man I need more testosterone so he
should have a set of bull balls and I
believe his [ __ ] should be simply too
big and the kind of things of
superheroes should be a fat dick I need
I need I can't have an average dick on
Batman
Laura's on so much sauce is ball shrunk
up now Brandon if you're gonna say
Batman does steroids I'm gonna probably
he's on physically attack he's doing
no no hold on let me rephrase that list
I don't mean like he's on some androids
I mean Batman's on all hold this to give
you another chance
Oh take off it back alright and cuz I'm
gonna come at you okay I know Brandon
Batman's all natural true or false
[Music]
sorry about that sorry about that
that's how ever Batman is just a rich
dude on TRT with cool gadgets he is
Superman Superman is a real dude who
probably doesn't have TRT I'd love to
have forms well technically Superman's
an alien but correct yeah
I just in comic books look at the way
they draw women fat tits big ass I just
expected more from Batman's dick by the
time Brennan came to my house in like it
was like 11:00 at night you had to drop
something off or pick something up it's
like when we kind we'd we just yeah like
six months if that and you should place
umbrella the wife and I answer the door
and he's looming over us and boots and
we had it we did we had bare feet on and
he looked at us and he oh hey do
anything because I'm gonna pick that
[ __ ] you know what I could kill you
both right now what no I could just got
goose to your heads and you would die do
we know this do we know how easy it
would be for me to kill both of you this
is so funny like was like oh my god and
then afterwards she goes that was weird
and I go but I but it was true like you
know he could kill us he goes hey I
don't care I don't know why did he see
us he fighters don't know I did that
when you see my back ripple and I pull
myself up like a champ like a chimp
through 30 times fast while talking to
you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift